ah 730 when we can start I'll start by
reading the emergency announcement
should we be required to evacuate
building would you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please well both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs where they
please allow others to exit the room
before they go to the fire escape door
where they can then be given assistance
our assembly point will be in the public
car parked at the side of the Civic
sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return the building until
given permission to do so by council
staff may also remind all members that
this meeting will be recorded and also
remind you to switch off or mute your
mobile phones okay item two sorry item
one apologies for absence we have
councillor a Mason and to be headed no
no you have no us okay
we have a substitute of council will
inform council Mason thank you
substitute on now so item to any non
members attending yes counselor to the
counselor duty pudding tell both shall
always sure as always I guess good
minutes of the meeting held on with 12
july two thousand sixteen are they
degrade and are you happy to meet
asylums a true rebel
item 4 to receive declarations of
interest there are none item 5 and this
is the only item other item on the
agenda and I'll call upon us so thank
you bottle sleeping on the toy is going
to read those out yes if you don't
believe anything Thank You chairman
thank you its members this report
follows the established established
format that the committee is used to
receiving an interested of a review and
a picture of the mid-year training
position arrangements agreed at the last
meeting are now in place so in progress
and the sun reference to that within
within the documents I thought paragraph
three point to change from previous
years because just picks out that some
special arrangements are put in place it
was quite a learning curve and useful
for the future around a lot of new
members that being having the all-out
election this time around
and I members probably wish to discuss
the reports the end games really there's
some recommendation at the end of our
mounting attendance member attendance of
training which is appendix and and the
content of of the training program today
subject to any discussion there Thank
You chairman hey John how many questions
of Amiens drugs in our school comes to
run as independent people as we are now
we were just to get the trading brochure
so that we could see what was being made
on and you know we need to attend as I
change you should have heard no I know
you have one no no I think I spoke to us
talk about this laughs at the last
meeting did you have did you come on
stand up I make sure you set one we just
have one produced so which is actually
sent out song so we still introduce
potential group because I'd have replied
to gone as I've tried to do huge times
to the standards one see that's what
we're all about yeah let me show still
thank you cannot be sent along yeah yeah
something about happy to have it music
this was by email that's what I saw them
do yeah yeah it was because of this body
nine years my name's Jimmy can we all
have a copy down and Lauren that pupils
yeah you should have the same way with
about two weeks ago I know receive
something ask us which one were going to
go to maybe there's a village we were
looking to chairman yes ma'am yep just
two from the parish point of view and
members are called the last meeting I
think was I mentioned that this deputy
leader i was going round to visit all of
the parachutes and I part of that I've
been asked him about the training side
of things on what head it's been some
interesting answers and and I haven't
visited them all yet so I can't give you
a full report but one of the things that
seems to be coming out the strongest is
four parishes and the larger ones
individually but the smaller ones
perhaps as a small group to go out and
give them the training rather than from
there
to come to us so that seems to be the
biggest single thing that they're asking
for so I once I've being around all the
other houses so I'll come back and let
you know thank you very much yes class
is there any sort of shared online
training I'll give you an example I'm go
on the development quitting and it sort
of lends itself to that that could be
shared i don't know there is such a
thing they exist because when we had the
and training shawm scrub we ran for
number scenarios and that was really
useful that's the sort of thing you can
do is online training I think a couple
of maybe of observations I think at the
last meeting part of what we're doing is
looking at online training as something
this committee can introduce in place of
some of what it what it does but I think
separately if there is something that
it's useful but yeah I mean we should be
aware of nationally sounds a good good
good type of thing yeah
doing shelter yeah we can raise it i
think our HR department have some
involved in organizing your learning so
I'm telling ugly repentance and see what
capacity inimical yeah i mean i'm not
suggesting we do you lie to ourselves
they didn't so if there's something is
when we exactly with we're looking at a
learning and something will come back to
this committee about it has becoming
part of form training but maybe stuff
out there that that sort of this is
between fall elearning and and and there
but but allows a little bit of learning
you know we didn't know it's compulsion
or is what I think you're thinking about
maybe in that that we should you know
look at
go see your hand up almost to an office
I mean they can be put in addition term
to the formal mandatory training than
this on the if if you can put in some
aspects of what we're talking man yeah
and then come to the phone you can see
woman yeah but the difference but it was
raised largely the last meeting with
with e-learning which officers do a bit
at the times you have got things like
pass marks and you know you have done
and it's it's producing something this
committee is happy with four members and
members will feel happy within the
formal context but it doesn't mean no
with all the subjects the council deals
with that there isn't useful additional
material that might be a little bit
interactive that doesn't if the
committee's happy with that officers be
mindful about own leaders we can start
flying that in this nice as well yeah
and I just mentioned remembers the
actually the opportunities by email well
oh yes I did I just want you to sort of
come back on this business that this
gentleman here and then I don't know how
to apology it's raised about you know
having some additional learning one of
the things that the last standards
training that I came to last you one of
the most valuable parts of that I felt
as the scenarios and that really got
people talking about it and that's the
sort of thing lookin good in all sorts
of talking so development all sorts
could go on an e-learning package though
you haven't got a huge amount to wade
through but you could actually it would
focus you on something but are actually
relevant to you and you could see that
you could actually learn from that I
think that would be what I did
remembers you so another question here
coming as is and that happy exactly
[ __ ] recommendations so we just need
to do with the recommendations first one
is to make the identity attendance by
local district councils at the training
courses in phase one program and
painting to report shall take them
separately can we tell them as motive
and to know the content to prefer your
program to date and the forthcoming
opportunities the remainder of twenty
sixteen to seventeen was bringing in
chairman the additional comments that we
made join the meeting thank you very
much for your help maybe
Oh